hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
one of our long-standing interests here
at mindscape is in the idea of
complexity
not just the simple systems that
particle physicists or cosmologists like
myself like to study
but the interesting phenomena that come
into existence when things have many
many many moving parts
and you can find emergent behavior that
might not have been
immediately obvious just from thinking
about the component parts
now we've talked about complexity we
talked about it recently with scott
aronson
but that was in the sense of
computational complexity how difficult
is it to solve a certain well-posed
puzzle here we're going to be talking
about complex systems so
either physical systems that you could
build up like a robot or for that matter
a human being
but also social systems information
systems the internet itself is a complex
system
so neil johnson is one of the experts in
this area an incredibly prolific
physicist who heads up a new initiative
at george washington
university in complexity and data
science and our conversation has two
different focuses the first part of the
talk will be about what is a complex
system what makes something complex how
do you know
how do you characterize it so various
words that you might have heard before
like
power law behavior will appear and neil
explains very very clearly
how power laws are different than bell
curves or other things that you might
run across in the natural world
but then we turn our attention to the
specific idea of
information systems and how people get
information in the real world
a lot of neil's recent research
interests are on how
extremism or conflict or various forms
of bad
behavior spread through complex networks
how do extremist groups
recruit their volunteers how does
disinformation
promulgate through social networks or
through official
news channels so this is as you might
guess scarily relevant stuff to the
modern world
he's a great explainer of things this
stuff is really important and
fascinating at the fundamental level
i think we're gonna learn a lot so let's
[Music]
go
[Music]
neil johnson welcome to mindscape
podcast great to be with you sean
you know we've talked about complexity
in some vague sense on the podcast
before
most recently with scott aronson where
he talked about computational complexity
p versus np kind of things
but your kind of complexity you're
interested in complex
systems which is a whole other kettle of
fish i mean why don't you
start us off by telling us what you
think of are the defining features when
we talk about a complex system
yeah um that's a great question
and it's very important to differentiate
between something that's complex and
something that's complicated
um you know our lives are now
complicated because we have to use all
these kind of online
platforms we don't know if we're going
to teach online or not
we don't we there are complicated issues
but complexity is something more than
that
and to give an idea um
let's just say let's imagine we're doing
something
complicated tonight we're gonna make a
pizza but we also gotta um
pick up one of the kids and we so we've
got to schedule these things that's
complicated
but imagine if each one of those pieces
now depends in some really complicated
way
on what's happened before and
there are other people doing things at
the same time that impact us so for
example if going out in the traffic
um well it matters that other people who
may have decided to go out
in the traffic with us are now come and
they're now congesting the road and
therefore affecting my
my my trait my chain of events so that
begins to move from
complicated to complex because there's
nothing that i could actually
interconnect to the other
meaning of complexity there's nothing
easy for me to compute
that would make the task ease that would
kind of predict what would happen
other than me going out and actually
doing it
so that's how it connects to the idea of
complexity in a computational sense it's
sort of like the length of the code that
you need you can't kind of simplify it
so i that that carries over to the
complex systems
view in the sense that um it's almost
like all the things that could happen in
the system
feedback across scales one local things
affecting
other things um you know the the driver
next to me affecting me but also the
fact that it's
that all the drivers have come out at
the same time for some unpredictable
reason
all of those things interact and make
the system complex now out of complex
out of that complexity therefore
surprising things can happen
they can suddenly emerge traffic jams
can emerge
um stock market crashes can emerge out
of nothing
and that is really where the interest in
complex systems
kind of comes to the fall yeah so i mean
i've do been doing these
videos recently called the biggest ideas
in the universe on some ideas in physics
and i've been i've been
pushing the idea that physics makes
progress via a spherical cow philosophy
where we ignore
all the complications and simplify down
to the bare bones and so in some sense
what you're saying is that
complex systems are exactly where that
doesn't work right where
yet where all the interactions between
all the different pieces really do feed
into the final result
correct and some of the things that we
as physicists
love to do like we assume that um
interactions don't depend
on time positions can depend on time but
the form of the interaction doesn't
depend on time
and it doesn't particularly depend on
maybe whether that
spherical cow has some kind of compass
needle inside that makes it different on
a monday morning than on a friday
afternoon and so those simplifications
that enable us to get
so far in physics um they don't work
yeah and but nevertheless like you just
said um
there are things we can say so that i
mean that's where complex systems become
interesting right where it's not just
well things are harder so we give up
it's there's a new kind of thing we can
start looking for
correct and the challenge is
finding that thing and i've been
scratching around in my career
and a lot of people are doing a lot of
important work in this area we're trying
to get you know you'd love
to have um something even
you know even you know approximate but
general in the sense that it's
reproducible
in these systems so it's that's a real
challenge you know these systems that
we're talking about the traffic they
don't consider
you know there's no there's no conserved
energy there's
there's no sense in which it's the same
at midnight as it is at 6
6 pm so somehow all these trends
all these symmetries that would have
helped us in the problem are just not
there
is it is it safe to say that um complex
systems research
is still in a kind of pre-paradigmatic
stage where you know we haven't
decided what are the crucial questions
or the
the the basic systems we can keep
returning to
yeah i think that's a great way of
summing it up you know my
um every semester my when i go in and i
i want to teach a class on on complex
systems
but you know what's the homework yeah
for the complex
you know what's the simple examples that
they can work out that show complexity
and yet are simple enough
in a homework that nobody's going to
turn around and say hey that wasn't
you know that homework couldn't even be
done that's where we
are and so it's funny because it's like
a double-edged
sword there's so much to explore but
that it can
look from the outside that there's you
know where's your schrodinger equation
where's your
hamiltonian you have nothing you have
nothing to show
and so yeah it's it's um it's
it's a challenge it's certainly a
challenge but nevertheless i'm sure you
have
some favorite examples that you do like
to lay on people
yeah i um particularly got interested
in the um this famous
example of uh the alfa roll problem
um this is very famous within the
complexity community no one else has
ever heard of it so you should
definitely
share it exactly exactly and you know i
was in um so i'll lead into the story
but
the the el farol is a bar in santa fe
new mexico
and you know i happened to be there um
recently before the before the
lockdown et cetera and i was taking
photos of myself against this
bar you know what are you doing who are
you
and of course you know as soon as i
speak with my accent it's like what are
you doing
what exactly are you doing is this some
is this a is this something of concern
but of course
what i was really doing was taking a
picture of a bar that has become famous
in the complexity field and in some
sense it was
uh you know john cassidy said she'd
solve the el faro problem and you solve
complexity so let me
maybe just to just explain what that
alfaro problem is
it's um it really embodies everything to
do with um complexity
here's this here's the situation and
i'll vary it a bit from brian arthur
brian arthur introduced that brian
arthur
is at the santa fe institute and he
introduced the following problem
um i'll vary some of the details but
it's essentially the same
so imagine there is some bar called
like for example el farol and you want
to go
there um a particular night a week say
tuesday nights you just happen to want
to go there there's a band playing that
you like
you just want to see them every tuesday
night you're not the only one
so there's some other number of people
who probably want to go there as well
now here comes the problem that the alfa
roll
bar being like many bars only has a
finite number of seats
and you want to sit um
and so does everybody else so one can
imagine the situation that every tuesday
rolls around the problem will do i
go or don't i go now if i go i've got to
get in the car i've got to go there
got to go through all that effort and i
might have to stand up
so i would lose in that situation if i
stay at home
and i hear that actually there were
enough seats maybe
you know my friend tells me the next day
hey you should have come to the alfa
roll there are plenty of seats
then i've lost as well and of course
there are the flip side of that there's
two ways to win i can
make all the effort and go and i find a
seat i win
or i stay at home and then my friend
says to me the next night yeah you were
right not to come
i win and so there's immediately so he
but he that sounds like a game and so
aha
that's not physics that's game theory no
because there is some indeterminate
number of people say 100 that i don't
know
i have no connection with and they're
doing they're trying to do the same
thing so imagine we all hit the same
strategy we all have the same in other
words we become identical objects or we
become rational in some way
so we all do the same thing that means
we either all
go or we don't it doesn't actually
matter what
individual role we follow we're either
all going or we're not and of course
that immediately becomes the wrong
thing to do and so brian arthur very
cleverly with this one simple example
set up the idea that i therefore have a
system
of objects that are heterogeneous
that don't have full information about
the system
maybe they know the last few weeks
whether it would have been good to go
or not and they've got to make some
decision
about what to do the next time they're
all trying to do the same thing
if they all do use the same strategy
it becomes a losing strategy so there's
this internal kind of frustration
we begin to be you know anyone who knows
you know if you know
the people who know things about spin
systems immediately you think
i don't care a bunch of meta-stable
states that
you know this thing is going to bounce
around between and that's the whole
point
but by the way i mean it's worth
noticing that there is something subtle
here because
for the paradigmatic question about
complexity this is a really
simple problem right the problem is not
complex
you go to the bar you don't that's
that's the question correct
and then that is the you you
absolutely hit the nail on the head it
sounds
so simple and there are so many other
examples you could think of
in in in in the world you know do i go
to the supermarket particularly now i
don't want it to be crowded
um in the sense that i may have to wait
in line to get inside so do i make the
effort or don't i
the traffic i've got two routes to go
home do i take this route or the other
route
the market do i buy or do i sell
it matters not that there's some
intrinsic value in the
it matters whether everyone else is by
same with housing market
do i buy when everyone else is buying
bad idea
so you get the idea that there's some
some varying and the
and the dynamics that come out of this
model and people have studied this
um the physics community has started
this a lot now since um
you know since the earth since the 90s
um the dynamics are so rich
and they go beyond any physical system
that we can really think of because
i as one particle i mean that's what i
love about the problem i could think of
myself as a particle what would i do
and of course i i take yeah i probably
remember something about the last three
weeks and then i've got some kind of
little
rule in my head that says if that
happened then do this um
and we're all probably doing something
like that it's it's a wonderful
so there's there's it's non-markovian
you know it depends on the past you know
it depends on the history yeah
and there's definitely feedback i will
adapt
that's the other thing these we're we're
particles that adapt
so we're heterogeneous we have memory of
the past
and we adapt so if it doesn't work i'm
going to change my system
probably to a worse one but i will
change and i guess
probably to a lot of people who hear
this problem they're going to say well
isn't the answer just like go 60
of the time randomly i mean why isn't
the answer that simple
yeah so we could do it whereby this um
i i have a some kind of loaded dice and
you know with a 10 on it there's 10 num
10 faces on its own
and i roll it so you know when it's the
first six numbers that's my 60
so um i would go then and i would stay
behind
so that would be a probabilistic way of
solving it but of course
i'm not going to sit around and wait for
that that's not the way i
roll and that's not the way i work i'm
not a random object
i take i have memory of the past i will
try and adapt i'm trying to
win and so this is where it gets really
interesting and
you could think of it connecting to
things in
smart materials where you do embed kind
of this agent behavior or even physics
itself
that that somehow the particle may be
trying to optimize
something or you know certainly minimize
its energy or do something like this
and if it has some kind of glassiness
some
memory of the past it's not going to
just be the equivalent of flipping coins
and so this is where we've the physics
community actually
you know this the so this elbow problem
is what really got me interested in
complexity
and um it i
naively thought that the um for example
the
economics and finance field would be
absolutely um they would love this
problem
but the you know still um nearly 20
years later
um it really they haven't really
embraced
what brian arthur was really talking
about um in terms of this
you know the the um in terms of this
inductive
behavior rather than absolutely being
able to compute
the ground state and then sticking with
it yeah
and i think it is because
it's it doesn't really fit in with any
of their paradigms
there is no rational act you can't even
perturb the rational actor there's no
equal
there may be an equilibrium of sorts but
it's really bouncing around between
meta-stable states
so it's much closer to what a physicist
would
like to hear about than what are the
some of the other
disciplines so what are i mean i'm just
trying to give the audience
a little bit more of a feeling for what
the solutions look like even if the
problem is not completely solved you
mentioned that there are meta-stable
states does that mean like
i go every week or i never go yes so
there's one particularly
interesting behavior that emerges
so and i've mentioned in the past that
uh you know complex systems can have
emergent
phenomena that's uh you know there's
something uh so what is that so i'm
gonna
so there is one a wonderful behavior
that happens um
there's a terror first of all to give
you the bad news the terrible behavior
is of course when we all think we have
the right rule and um and then when we
change our rule we change it
in similar ways and so we're always
doing the wrong thing that would be a
huge
crowd phenomenon right whereby a whole
crowd go or they don't go so the
fluctuations in that system would be
of the size of the number of particles
which
is um that's an that's that's a system
instability um
which which is interesting in itself but
there's a wonderful emergence state that
arises
that you can think of in the following
way imagine your art you and i
are following our little rule for
how we're going to decide whether to go
and we begin to diverge in how we change
our rule
and other people are following more
closely
you and just inadvertently or me
in terms of how we adapt our strategy
and we can adapt we can
develop into effectively a crowd
following one strategy
and a crowd which i would call an
anti-crowd
following the opposite strategy neither
strategy is good
nor bad because it sort of it just
depends on what everyone else is doing
but imagine out of those 100 people 50
are following a rule that says
go on the i mean it wouldn't be as
simple as that but go on the odd number
weeks
and then the other 50 over doing will go
on the even
number of weeks um so they don't know
each other they haven't coordinated any
sense they just kind of
end it up they don't have a facebook
group
that's right they had no facebook poll
which brings us up to they'll bring us
on so i'll get there
you'll get there later but the um but
without any coordination without any
local information just
global information fed back to them like
some external
field being sending them news global
news
and they've managed to split themselves
into a 50 even a 50
which means that if you look at the if
you're the bar manager and you're
looking at the
system output in other words how many
people are actually sitting in your bar
you're hitting 50 50 50 50 you have no
fluctuation
yeah perfect and even if we all
tossed coins that were actually not even
based on 60 40 pretend we don't even
know what the seating is
um we just toss a coin to cyber to go
that has fluctuations in it because
right you know 60 heads 40 tails 70
heads with 30 tails
um but that's that that
end result that system result purely
driven from competition
of the 50 and 50 gives no fluctuation in
the system
so that begins to make you wonder
goodness
is it possible that i could even design
then
many complex systems whether they be
i don't know could be drones could be
things
you know that don't want to get in each
other's way it could be um
um something in a biological system
could i
if i can could one way of be controlling
complex systems b
to kind of nudge them so that half of
them are following
one strategy and half of them are
following the opposite strategy or even
if there were
many many strategies make sure that
they're sort of paired up
in opposites um that would be that's
that's a wonderful
outcome from that studying that very
very simple problem
want to pause to talk about
policygenius.com an insurance
marketplace that is built and backed
by a team of industry experts a lot of
people are wondering whether right now
it's even possible to buy life insurance
and the answer is yes
it is possible and in fact if you have
other people loved ones who depend on
your income
maybe this is a good time to think about
doing it the steps are very simple you
head to policygenius.com
where in minutes you can work out how
much coverage you need and you can
compare
quotes from different top insurers to
find your right price
you apply for the lowest price that
applies to you
and the policy genius team will handle
all the paperwork and all the red tape
policy genius works for you not for the
insurance company so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they will take care of everything that's
the kind of service that has earned
policy genius a five-star rating across
over 1600 reviews on trustpilot and
google
so if you need life insurance head to
policygenius.com right now to get
started you could save fifteen hundred
dollars or more
per year by comparing quotes on their
marketplace
policy genius because when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right
well i think this is this i i like that
that uh
possible solution has been given because
that's how we see that this very simple
problem is
a paradigm for complexity because that
emergent feature that you wouldn't have
guessed right without
central planning or even explicit
cooperation
some kind of pretty good solution
emerges out of
uh people trying their best individually
correct and actually it's probably even
better than trying to do it top down
imagine you're actually calling up the
people
and saying to them well you're one of
this group
or you're one of the opposite group this
week
um would they listen to you yeah so the
fluctuations that will come out of
trying to force people to do something
would be even worse would be worse yeah
than the ones that come out of
competition
this is a slight uh deviation from the
line here but um
your discussion reminded me of a
question that has been
uh working at me for a while like
game theory which is a theory of you
know making decisions under situations
of competition and perhaps incomplete
information etc etc
is game theory secretly physics like can
we reduce it all to statistical
mechanics you know optimizing some
utility function kind of sounds like
minimizing some hamiltonian or some
action or something like that
sean i would i think you should go out
and write that book i wanted to first
one to
i will buy it and i will because i think
you're right
yeah in fact um you know there are lots
of hints of that in the
um particularly in the type of um
you know probabilities that are you the
forms of the probability that are used
by
quote-unquote agents look very much like
two-level systems
in a finite at a particular temperature
the probabilities the maximum weightings
and so you're absolutely right i wish
i'd have had that graduate course
when i was doing my phd that would have
just kind of laid the scene
instead i've had to kind of learn it the
hard way from standing up
standing up and having game theorists
call out oh what you're telling me is
game theory and i feel like saying okay
actually what you're telling me is
physics but so so this is something that
you agree is
is sounds kind of trueish but it is not
an accepted fact that has been well
known since von neumann or something
like that yeah
although um i mean there are there there
are
even closer there's it's remarkably
there's a
area of game theory now after all these
years
after you know here seeing beautiful
mind and all these things with two gay
two-player games um there's now an area
of game theory called
mean field okay there we go mean field
game theory
physicist so
this has emerged in
pretty recently and it purely
inspired by physics the idea that mean
field approximation it's funny because
you know in physics if you go around
saying i'm just going to do mean field
theories people will very quickly tell
you when mean field theories break down
but the the game theory community have
as they've tried to get towards more and
more players
have realized that there's no way they
can write out
exactly what each of these 10 to the 23
players will be doing
so they need some kind of
renormalization
of the system and that comes through
this mean field game so i if there is an
area which would really really profit
from um people from the physics
community joining with people from the
games
neither have got the right answer yeah
um but that is
really a particularly for the dynamics
i think how things get towards
equilibria or avoid equilibria that's
the interesting
bit yeah you know and as they said you
know in the end we're all
you know in the long run we're all dead
equilibrium is death
so every system we're interested in all
of us
you know whether even expansion of the
universe that's a non-equilibrium system
so it's the it's the it's the behavior
away
from the dead state that we're all
interested in but that is the hardest
and physicists themselves are not that
great at that as
as i know from experience but correct
you um
but you also you you mentioned some
phrases
that i want to sort of repeat because it
reminds us how this is not a simple
physics problem even if there is some
version i mean you mentioned adaptive
agents and also rational
agents i mean part of the what makes in
my mind complex systems different
uh than just physics systems is that you
know we're not dealing with particles
that are
dumb and memoryless and just bounce off
each other right like part of what makes
a complex system is that we assemble it
out of
individual pieces that themselves have
some structures and and maybe even goals
and memories and things like that
absolutely correct and so one of the
challenges i'm particularly involved in
in my
my my own work is how can i embody that
in the simplest possible way
that kind of internal character it
always reminds me of einstein's phrase
of the um you know kind of hidden
variable
um how can we put in
how can we put in some kind of
characteristic
that is simple enough that captures what
you just said
um captures that adaptiveness etc but
doesn't go overboard
and suddenly become you know i need a
whole book just to explain one person
yeah okay well but you know that's why
it's interesting so that's
so i think we have a good feeling now
about what complex systems can be and
how they arise but
despite the fact that it is still
arguably pre-paradigmatic
some things appear over and over again
and one of the obvious things i'm
thinking about are power laws
uh maybe you can explain to the audience
what a power law is why we care
and are you someone who thinks that
looking for power laws is a very
important thing or do you think it's
overrated
that's a fantastic question well the um
so just to set the scene
um we talked about coins tossing coins i
think it's imagine if we all toss coins
uh toss 100 coins pretty much 50
55 60 not so often
70 very infrequently 80
would come out as heads so there's a
distribution of outcomes and that
distribution
looks like uh um goes up has a single
peak it's a bell curve
it's a bell curve so um
we do we as a society we do a lot
with bell curves we assess
risk we think about medicine
in terms of bell curves we think about
the average
patient response and we should do i mean
that's a very reasonable thing to do
if on average people have some kind of
average
behavior of course in medicine you'd
think that the biology is has an average
you know and maybe there's fluctuations
but there's some
kind of average behavior but when you
get in and look at social
systems and actually a lot of physical
systems as well
there these averages do not
necessarily characterize the system very
well
think about the i mean it's a very
topical thing now of course wealth
the distribution of wealth in the
country a lot of people
have little very few people have a lot
right but that distribution looks
nothing like a bell curve
there is no kind of here's the average
and then there's a few outliers
you know one in a one in a billion has
more than twice the you know or more
than three times than
the the average wage we all know that
that is not true
in fact that tale of wealth goes on a
long long way
and um you're in a situation where
almost everyone is below
average right and so
if you're doing and of course the
economist do not do this
um taking you're building an economy
around the average and assuming that
everyone who has the average
income and then plus or minus you know
ten dollars here and there
you know then all houses would have to
be the same price
um you know and there would be no
high-end restaurants
yeah it would lit because that would be
everything that would be
available to us so um we know that in
um other real world settings we have
nothing like a bell curve
now here comes the problem bell curves
are wonderful
for calculating things like risk and the
odds of something being um you know
an unlikely event um
and we can calculate lots of things we
build buildings based on
a bell curve we assume that you know
nobody comes in the
room that is somebody can come in at six
foot but they're not going to come in at
6 000 feet
yeah of a height right and um
and if we did that i mean if that were
the case that
every so often every you know once in
every nine months you get somewhat of
six thousand feet
suddenly buildings would be that we we
would have lost the purpose of buildings
right so um it's ingrained in the way we
think that some things are bell curves
and some things
are other kind of distribution the
problem is we don't really have a good
mathematics of
of other these other distributions that
are so called fat tails where
somebody can be earning a thousand times
what somebody else is
is earning and and so those fatal
distributions
are a problem now in physics
we are pretty used to those type of
distributions
a particular form of them are called
power laws
and the power law is characterized by
the fact that
what happens at one scale
is exactly the same as what happens at
another scale it's just kind of
twice as much or half as much now let me
give you an example
um scientists and physicists
in particular are fairly convinced seem
fairly convinced that
things like um earthquakes uh
follow a power law or might follow an
approximate power law which means
there's there's a very deep consequence
of that it's not just that
well there could be very big earthquakes
it the consequence is that
it's scale free the behavior in other
words what's happening
earthquakes of a certain size is the
same as what's happening for earthquakes
of twice the size
just just at a different scale now that
that so the consequence of that is if
you were building a theory of big
earthquakes dangerous big earthquakes
you really should just build use the
same theory that worked
at lower scales in other words the the
science
carries over from scale to scale it's
not like there's some
new phenomenon that suddenly appears
as you get to earthquakes of a certain
size so that idea of scale free is a
very
powerful thing in science and
particularly in physics because that is
the distribution that occurs
when a system tends to be near some kind
of phase transition so-called
transition between system behaviors to
just give an example forest fires
are another example talks about
earthquakes let's talk about forest
fires
forest fires um at the um
transition between no fire across the
system and
fire spreading everywhere they tend to
have um
a power law distribution in the kind of
clusters
that are burning for example um so this
idea that
power laws exist at critical junctures
in complex systems is a very powerful
one and a true one
let me jump in just a second here
because i think i remember back when i
was a graduate student
and i was confused sometimes by
the phrase phase transition being
invoked in in different circumstances
because i think of phase transitions of
like you know melting ice or freezing
water
and there are things that happen over
time but
when you talk about the forest and the
or the earthquakes being having
distributions
of sizes of events that are
characteristic of phase transitions it's
not
because i think correct me if i'm wrong
the forest is literally
literally undergoing a transition from
one face to another
it's that there could be different
phases and the forest is sort of
perpetually stuck in between them is
that
is that basically right great that's a
fantastic
observer you're absolutely correct so
a shortcoming of the current
understanding
of power laws and phase transitions is
that they happen
exactly you know you sit the system
there and it's either there or it's in
another
um situation getting it to describing
how something would happen in
time is the area of dynamical phase
transitions which is a really
that's a much newer area of physics
because it's a system out of equilibrium
one can talk about systems it quite
unquote in equilibrium i'm going to set
the fire the forest
you know just at the it's just at its
critical point just where the fire would
spread or it wouldn't spread yeah okay
but that's stationary in time
but if i'm thinking of something
beginning to spread and i'm fanning it
or i'm
adding things in from the outside you
know
more trees it would be equivalent or for
a coveted outbreak for example
more people more susceptible people that
gets into the dynamics
the dynamical phase transition that's a
much harder
um situation to describe but the
the relevance of the power law is still
there right because
you can imagine situations where i have
a whole bunch
of objects affected which would be a
huge
event that's like having one person have
a whole bunch of
all the money in the world or i can
imagine many times it would just be
you know just like a few example
many times it would just be a few
objects that are affected so that's
that's the whole the rest of us that are
not earning very much
yeah um so the power laws are pretty
ubiquitous now there has been of course
a uh an interesting debate and the um
literature is do well is it really a
power law is it approximately about law
but um but putting that i i think that's
a little bit
um that's getting a little bit too
inside baseball
yeah because in the end we could do an
experiment
right homes as well now we do experiment
on a phase
transition and and we could try and map
out the size of the clusters
even though it's a correct phase
transition because of the way we're
measuring it we haven't got all the
information we're not
recording it properly we make mistakes
we're not
never going to get a perfect power law
so um the power law is more indicative
that there's
the system is on some kind of tipping
point right i guess that's
that's what i wanted to get into because
i think that sometimes from the outside
people see
various kinds of uh in various kinds of
disciplines people
show power laws they debate what the
exponent of the power law is or whether
it is a power law or whatever but
but the thing that gets missed is the
reason why we
care is because the existence of a power
law might be
pointing to some physical mechanism that
that creates this right
it's a different kind of physical
mechanism that would create a bell curve
correct and so the fascinating thing
then becomes hey yeah
i may have two systems that have power
laws if they've got
the same slope that's a little bit like
an exponent
that that's like saying two mountains
that are both red slopes yeah
for skiing if if they've got that they
may be a
similar mechanism behind them and one of
those mountains maybe in
europe the other may be in california
and it doesn't
matter there's something about the way
that mountain got created that
gave it the same slope right and so it
gives the hope
that there may be some simple kind of
mechanism that and this is where we get
into
you know i've worked in my in my um in
my work in this area we've we've worked
on
things to do with uh casualties and wars
i said
you can get into a lot of hot water
talking about this
um in this way but
it's actually a fact that when you look
at casualties from conflicts for example
um they can be very different conflicts
from very different parts of the world
different
motivations if they they have this they
they they
have very similar power law
slopes exponents which means that at the
end of it
just somehow in the way that humans are
doing things
is the same in both places the
mechanisms
it's how humans do conflict like it's
how
rocks get put together to make a red
slope mountain
well i mean this is a perfect segue
because that's exactly what i wanted to
do roll up our sleeves a little bit and
get into the applications and i know
that you've been very heavily involved
in
conflict and radicalization uh and and
very
i don't know why you've chosen a whole
bunch of ways that people die as your as
your
complex systems to study but we won't go
into that but uh
you know so what is the so when we talk
about these things
a power law of what what is it that
we're actually studying
yeah that's a great question actually i
will do a little quick shout out of why
on earth i would
end up in there um steve strogatz
cornell um previous mindscape guest
ah fantastic um he
i he once said um
that he studies the particular things i
think it was in reference to his romeo
and juliet uh studies
dynamics yeah he finds it interesting to
look at topics that are somehow taboo
and that stuck with me yeah um
that that's an interesting area just
because it's
unpleasant the fact that there's now
data
a lot of data so my interest in this
grew through the iraq war
and the other wars that were going on
um and that was like you know in
colombia were going that's what
suddenly wait a minute i i can look
we can look at these two wars let's
forget
all the thousands of books have been
written on their motivations and they're
consequent
just look at the numbers the number of
people that get
fatalities per day something like this
or per event
um what would we see so that's how we
got off on that and actually this goes
back to
as uh lewis fryer richardson was a um
effectively he was a physicist they
ended up looking at me meteor
um what kind of weather patterns etc but
he in the first world war um got in his
head
that somehow to understand the human
condition
um human conflict he would just track
numbers
of people in casualties so i'm so saying
a number of casualties
in in wars so we did the same thing he
didn't have the benefit
of knowing in the individual events
in a conflict how many people were
killed he just did had the totals for
wars which is more
kind of messy you get a messier result
but during the early 2000s um
when unfortunately of course there was
iraq
a war going on um afghanistan was going
on
colombia was going on we started to
look in exactly the same way same lens
at these three conflicts and also glow
and terrorism there are terrorist events
we looked at we looked at all of these
in the same way
in the and it was as follows we looked
at the number of casualties per event
so for example okay there may be five
days where nothing happens and then
there's something happens and it
this number of people were killed and we
just literally
plotted it out as a histogram like you
would plot out
how many people earn a certain amount of
money it's now how many events
had a certain amount of fatalities
and i think we did i'm not sure
what we expected to see i think isn't
that always the beauty you know
really show web science people say what
did you expect to see i
i i'm not sure um but you might have
expected to see something like a bell
curve you might have expected that well
you know maybe in iraq um with a
particular kind of
capability um among the
insurgency um they would create a
certain
average number of fatalities every time
they decided to get involved in some
event
and then there'd be kind of fluctuations
around that yeah there's some kind of
best kind of attack that they just did
over and over again yes but that's not
what we found
so what we found was actually more like
the mountain slope more like the
um histogram of of of
income we found lots of events where
very very few fatalities
and then and then there's a whole
spectrum
up to a few events that were absolutely
huge
in fatalities and
when we so we did the statistical test
etc etc
um to check that the that it was um a
good goodness of fit as they say for the
power law
and when we looked at the slopes what we
found was
um we were looking at iraq colombia by
that time
word got out and we were being sent all
these data sets from all these different
wars that
some of which we'd never even heard of
um but when we looked at them
now there's an important point a lot of
these were
wars that were involving some kind of
large state
with some kind of organic
if we would can call it that opposition
um
not like world war ii kind of words
right not like and certainly not like
the hollywood movie you know line them
up at dawn
and two massive armies just well which
is an interesting point interesting
scientific point because
the that hollywood picture of just line
up at dawn on opposing sides and just
you know basically keep going till
nobody's left standing that's like
if you think about it in a kind of
abstract way that's like a test tube
of two reacting species that kind of
just
interact all day and there's nothing
left at the end of it except the product
um but these other the modern wars they
crack the insurgencies and this is where
again we got into
pretty um interesting territory with the
social sciences of what whether you call
it an insurgency or it's a
narco gorilla in the end
these are the numbers yeah these are the
numbers we got power laws and they
all had the same slope which is like
saying i've gone round
my i'm gonna go around the world look at
all the mountains oh my goodness they've
all got the same slope
right which is not true in the real
world for for mountains but
which is not true in the real world for
mountains but it
was true and still and so we published
this like in um 2009
and we were expecting a deluge of
people sending us results that were not
power laws therefore
and didn't have and even if they were
parallels didn't have the same slope
but to this day interestingly
now that we have much better data sets
and there are
many many um people of now
into the counting the dead if i can call
it that
um science uh in the social sciences and
actually doing a remarkable job
of counting um fatalities per event
still to this day the the
the this idea that their power holds up
and they all seem to have the slope
around around the red slope which in
this this case is a 2.2.5
slope it's remarkable and it's actually
the same as the
um slope for terrorist events so um
this is and since then we've come up
with some physics models to try and
explain that physics based models in
which have to do with the way that
particles unlike
the hollywood situation of everybody
lining up in a you know
kind of mimicking what goes on in a test
tube it's more the idea that um
objects insurgents form into clusters
and it's the what you're seeing is
really the clustering attack
you see a cluster attack and so it's
more to do with the way in which people
form
clusters so human beings forming
clusters between them i mean maybe maybe
that's worth
going into more because um when i think
of these power laws like you mentioned
classically
uh income uh the the explanation that
comes to mind is the rich get richer
right it's not just a random
distribution of money
uh once you have money you can get more
and so you there's a few
billionaires and a lot of poor people
but for terrorist attacks
uh they seem more independent of each
other and so so but
but you're hinting that the that there's
some network phenomenon that explains
some agglomeration of attackers
that can help give us this power law yes
correct
um the and and it comes down to a very
very simple story if we
if you and we could do this now we sit
in we could either write it out with
pencil and paper or do it on a
in a simulation if you take the simple
rule
that people for example for this case we
talk about an insurgency
since they're fighting some very strong
um state army or coalition army
they need to group together into
something
that is pretty substantial so they're
trying to group together they're trying
to coalesce
into some kind of cluster however
they are every so often being broken up
because just like you know you look at
fish fish
under the you know all these national
wonderful now that we're all at home
watching national geographic
programs um you know you see the fish
gradually coalesce they coalesce they
coalesce
and then they get sense that there's a
predator
and they scatter they fragment and that
simple simple simple rule of coalesce
coalesce and then occasionally fragment
remarkably gives exactly it not only
does it give a power law
it gives a power law with a 2.5 slope
and so for all these years since 2009
we've been carrying this this is our
little story waving our little banner
saying that well i understand that yes
they could be
leftists they could be rightist they
could be this they could be that they
could be fighting in a jungle they could
be
they could have cell phones they may not
have self in the
end i'll just give them two properties
they gradually aggregate well not
gradually they just aggregate
and then they've and they fragment now
make one slight addition to that
the distance between them is
not as important as you might in other
words it's not we're not going to we
make it so good so that they can
aggregate over
arbitrary distances now what do we mean
by that
what we really mean is that they're
really kind of just coordinating
over arbitrary distances and that that
that's actually known for most of those
wars that we talked about in 2003
onwards there were cell phones
there were people coording so they would
coordinate um
to do to um you know do things in two
places at once for example
um so the idea of coalescence without a
distance
and um fragmentation gives you the 2.5
now since then lots of people have
studied it we've
also done our own made our own efforts
you can put in distance you can do all
this
it doesn't really get too far away from
what what i just said
and the beautiful thing is and this is
the graduate problem that i always said
on my complex systems course
and show with pencil and paper that
that's true right and it's really
it's two and a half pages and i and you
you remember i remember
doing a lot worse homework problems oh
yes
that's very interesting and actually the
way that you explained it there
makes it seem very transparent to those
of us who
who know a little bit about complexity
that it resembles the classic
uh sand pile avalanche problem right
like you you dribble sand
onto the sand pile and it will
occasionally uh
set off an avalanche and so it it grows
slowly
but that it it collapses uh all at once
correct and so what i like about this is
i you know i'm
i always feel that every day i woke up
in this complex distance field i know
less than i did the day before um but
it's that
model that i just is helping me
understand now i understand what
um what they meant by punctuated
equilibrium now i understand what they
meant by
you know so you can go back and look at
these related ideas
um and say aha
now i see how to kind of unify it's not
that
we've come up with some fantastic
mechanism and others didn't have it
others were probably on the point of
having that as well
maybe we're getting towards a unified
science yeah
so this is an overly ambitious question
so feel free to punt it but
one of the one of our first guests on
mindscape was jeffrey west
and he talked about his scaling laws
that have these one quarter powers right
one quarter three quarters etc
and he claims to have a mechanistic
explanation that relies on the fact that
he's talking about biological organisms
or spatial systems that
exist in three-dimensional space and the
four in his power laws is three plus one
if
if it were a different number of
dimensions of space it would be a
different
uh fraction rather than four is there a
similar feel-good story you can tell
about the 2.5 slope that you get
um i i think he's trumped me on that one
he got
he got he got a he he wins that one
because that's a that's a fantastic way
of seeing it the
the 2.5 interestingly is
it's a little bit more involved the the
explanation
but it it there are two levels of
explanation
first is that um power laws between
two and three actually have um
if you were to calculate their standard
deviation which is
that the size of the fluctuations it
actually diverges
and so there are systems that are in
some sense
infinitely adaptable they can form small
clusters they can form large clusters
and
in a way that's kind of like an
evolutionary advantage so
it being between two and three and slap
bang in 2.5
sort of makes sense now that is that's a
less
direct answer but the more direct answer
in the two and three is
interestingly if you
now add in the distance and make those
clusters form in a two-dimensional space
that exponent moves from 2.5 down to two
and that makes more sense because
they're now on a 2d space 2.5 is really
it's like clusters are forming they're
not in 2d they're not in 3d they're sort
of in between
um but i don't like that a particular
explanation what i do
prefer is actually the one that 2.5 is a
good
thing for a system that is trying to
compete and win
well that i guess that was um a set of
questions i had
um as as a physicist who's just sort of
trying to get into complexity myself but
you know who grew up doing
nice clean things like gravity and
particle physics etc
um you know these are all open systems
that you're talking about
right i mean they're they're dynamical
they exchange information
and energy with their environment
they're affected by the outside world
um is there something is there some
story to be told about
entropy and free energy and dissipation
that that helps us understand why these
systems settle into
this kind of power law or is that
something that uh
would be different for every system or
we don't even know yet i think it's a
fantastic question
that would be a that's a fantastic i
know that there are there there is
certainly work going along on that
there's no definitive answer that i
that i personally know of but one would
think that
and i think it's such an important
question that you just asked because
sometimes you answer that and you've
answered this kind of science of life
well because life itself is nothing more
than
us trying to keep ourselves away from
the equilibrium
and so exactly what goes on in a
non-equilibrium
system as it's it's heading towards the
inevitable
however on its way it can do all sorts
of wonderful things
and um getting an idea of that
beyond just the kind of idea that well
over time entropy increases so we're all
going to just
yeah it's it's the dynamics of that
which i
it it is not worked out so you're
absolutely right with that i think it's
absolutely the pertinent question to ask
no clear answers yet yeah i mean it
might be
um speculative but i mean
can you imagine that there's some
principle that will someday hit on that
this sort of power law
scale-free distribution either maximizes
or minimizes some entropy or entropy
production rate is that the kind of
thing we might be looking for
like this this complicated tree a
network system
lets us use uh use up entropy as
efficiently as possible
yes i think that might be correct and
particularly if we take the
vision of sorry the interpretation of
entropy as an information
exactly yeah measure then in that case
i'm absolutely worthy on that
that i do think it kind of comes down to
a sort of
and and and in that sense then living
systems are in some sense playing an
information game with the rest of nature
and so they're kind of borrowing
information for a while they're giving
it back
you know there's in us in a similar way
that one might think of as an
entropy of the entire system increasing
but the subsystem is
locally over time giving and taking yeah
yeah and it
it's so exciting to talk about these
things because it's so hard
in particle physics or cosmology to ask
a question that on the one hand we don't
know the answer tube on the other hand
we can hope to find an answer
whereas in complex systems there's all
these questions we don't know the answer
to they're pretty easy to hit on
yeah well sometimes on a monday morning
i'm really jealous of
the other of the others what are we
actually the grass is always greener i
know yeah
yes but the story you told about
um uh the the power law in
these these attacks uh sounds robust
enough
with the you know agglomeration and then
dissipation that it must be
more widely applicable like what kinds
of other systems should we be thinking
about
well when we went and looked online
at the growth in support
for isis during 2014 2015.
there the clusters are um
their their communities online and we
found
a pretty perfect 2.5 power law
so um because again people are trying to
connect together into communities and
occasionally that in that case they were
getting broken up
by the social media company by the
moderator because it violated the
turtles violent you know discussing
violence and
radicalism um it broke so we we've got
again that idea of
coalescence and fragmentation and
so we um we we were able to show that
you get exactly the same
um result of this 2.5 pounds or so in
some sense we've
uh that that that helps it helps
think about and frame um
what people do when they're trying to
fight against
the system in some way and so that gives
you insight into probably other so
could we even take something like um
some of these other um far right
radical uh groups and and do the same
thing well that preliminary results
suggest that
that suggests that we can and of course
that then completely changes the way
that you
might think about mitigating the build
up
online so most of the
strategies of mitigation schemes that we
see are
coming from the social sciences they're
very much detailed very much focused on
the bad actor the bad apple which is a
little bit like saying i'm going to stop
water boiling by taking out the bad
molecule
oh that's a i mean a analogy yes
right you know okay i'll take the one
with the fastest velocity going
up you know perpendicular to the surface
because that's the one that may be most
likely to
yeah but get rid of that one there'll be
another one right
and then there's another one and so you
really need us
and you know as physicists we would
never do who would imagine introductory
physics where we're going to discuss
every molecule in a glass of water
before it boils you'd never get anywhere
and that
you'd be fired um so um
so having a system view and saying hey
as this extremist movement whatever it
is
isis beyond the next version of it
which we hope it won't be but you know
there will be extremes
um the next one it will whatever it is
it will be preceded by a buildup of
clusters online
that will form into a power law with a
slope of 2.5 and the corollary of that
is when you begin to see that happen
worry yeah and so it completely changes
the kind of focus of how you might go
around
trying to detect
concerns you know the kind of threats
well so you can even though the slope
might be universal the hope is that
nevertheless there's a
sort of a normalization right yeah
there's there's more little ones than
big ones but still the absolute number
is something we can hope to increase or
decrease
yes and it then becomes down to maybe
that the world will then need to turn to
the physicists to um help with
deciding policy i've been telling them
but yeah they don't they don't listen to
me but
so so i just just want to drive this
home because
the the story you told can seem
frustrating if you think that well as
soon as these clusters grow big enough
we're imagining these are clusters of
things we don't want like you know
terrorist attacks or extremist groups or
something
uh so they grow big enough and you can
smash them and they disperse but then
they just
agglomerate again right i mean that but
you're not giving us a
just uh a sad story you're giving us a
strategy as well
yeah because and you just said it they
the big ones grow from the small ones
the big ones will probably be harder to
tackle
because they're robust they're just
they've got more eyes
um in we know they're they're more aware
of what's
what what's around but they come from
small ones
so maybe there's a strat that
immediately suggests like the sample
analogy
to prevent the big avalanches avalanches
in the sample just
just take care of the small ones so that
they don't build into big ones because
the big ones
need the small ones the bit to build
them so
one could imagine um an alternative
strategy and i'm not saying
i mean it's not as simple as that but
there's a kind of a
systems engineering uh complex systems
engineering
whereby you're not controlling i mean
look
look at all the issue with the social
media companies that
they seem to um you know go out and get
the bad the bad actors
bad influences online what that's very
hard
to do first of all you've got to find
them if they even exist if we're all on
a spectrum of
good to bad which i you know maybe we
could debate that but uh
yeah make them maybe people are bad in
certain moments et cetera
maybe that that's that first of all
you'd have to find them and then you'd
have to stop being sued by them
if you tried to remove them they maybe
they have quite powerful people and so
they're going to turn around
and or maybe they'll but they're maybe
they'll by you
by you removing them that will create
even more support
for them so you don't want to you know
so that it gets off into those type of
issues
is there a systems a complex systems
engineering i mean i don't even know
that there is no discipline of that yet
really
but is there a way of engine kind of
you're kind of
nudging the system in a way that then
doesn't impinge on one
one per one one of these objects can't
say hey you targeted me
um you're more nudging the system and
that for me is the
is that is the light at the end of the
tunnel of all of a lot of the systems
that we worry about
in society it's more no i think we're
thinking about them wrong
i think we should be thinking of kind of
almost like nudging
nudging the the nudging the and i don't
how we could say nudging the chemistry
in it changing the um
chemical potential somehow right
something like that
something like um you're changing maybe
if i could just
stop some of those smaller clusters
coalescing so fast
that would stop the flow through to the
bigger ones
they would then be isolated in some
sense um
so yeah i think there's a lot of mileage
there
to be gained from from the jump
and it's going to be an uncomfortable
jump but making that
or building that bridge from what we do
in our
academic studies of complex systems to
the policy field
and now i'm in dc i i i actually have to
say that i've had
remarkably good uh uh feedback and
interaction with um
policy people here i was i'm
pleasant really pleasantly surprised
well i mean we started by saying that
one of the interesting things about
these complex systems is you have these
individual agents
and they nevertheless seem to have
emergent collective behavior that was
not
given to them by top down and so in some
sense can we
can we imagine the difficulty these
these kinds of conflicts
uh coming from the fact that
the bad actors are acting like
individual agents complex systems coming
together
whereas the white knights trying to
combat them are more top down i mean
i remember reading something in
something you did about how
uh facebook pages that we're trying to
give good advice
to people to fight the pandemic
were all kind of boring and they said
the same thing over and over again
while the crazy ones said a million
different things so they were more
likely to hit
someone in their sweet spot of uh
vulnerability
yeah absolutely that's absolutely
correct and of course this hits the big
big challenge for um if anyone wants to
work on complex systems now
is the time because this the
the number one complex system in my head
now is
the online ecology involving
trust distrust of science distrust of
medical science
mixed in with the growing resistance to
potential vaccines misinformation
disinformation um
that that that is the
that is the that is the system to in my
view
be be working on um and
it's precisely as you just said that the
um
it's almost like an in i mean it's i
don't mean it in a
kind of political sense to call it an
insurgency but you've got some kind of
organic
clustering going on which in some sense
is much stronger
than the top down i'll go to this uh
website to learn about vaccines um
and because it's each one of these
clusters in some sense
to some degree autonomous for it's you
know
they've each developed their own flavors
and so giving them the
oh here's the best vanilla ice cream in
the world it's like no i don't want that
actually i like this other flavor you
know i'm not interested in that
oh um you know we see this actually on
the uh
in the online clusters the communities
in facebook and
you know we study this a lot we study
across platforms the
clusters that form and their
interconnections and how they
evolve over time we see this that
they're um
they they're they're talking about
effectively strawberry
strawberry ice cream that they love it
although they're talking really to put
it in concrete times they're talking
about some of them are now you know some
of them may be talking about will be no
safety there's no five years of safety
for the kova vaccine
and that's actually they're absolutely
right um
and then suddenly at the top appears
where they had these
lovely pictures of a baby's hand and you
look us off and they're talking about
you know
his parents who love their kids your
parents love their kids so
it's a wonderful they have a wonderful
message um
but then there's a suddenly a banner
appears at the top from
you know facebook's cdc um
saying oh we know effectively um if you
want to know about vaccines go to this
website
and it just it's it's like parents
coming into the room
yeah you know when you're trying to
develop some kind it's like don't do
this do that
so now you're not addressing the
the flavor of this cluster so yeah we're
studying that a lot now
well there's the famous story that i've
heard attributed to john wheeler but it
could be
somebody else or it could just be
completely apocryphal about you know
physicists always get
crackpot theories in the mail and uh
this physicist who might have been
wheeler had the strategy
of putting the crackpots in touch with
each other so that they could you know
you know talk to each other but they
always came back to him and said like
why are you
putting that person in touch with me
he's a crackpot like
just because you're a crackpot doesn't
mean you're sympathetic to other
crackpots right so there's many
different ways to be
wrong in this particular thing but that
actually helps the wrongness grow
in some sense because there's there's so
many different uh
buttons to push
it it does and and that's what we saw
with our um
you know the why the support for isis
grew so quickly it wasn't that it was
there was some coherent message between
them all it's just that what they were
opposing
was such an obvious it was such an
obvious target
and so you could oppose it in many many
ways it's like
you know in a two-spin system it's not
like you were the opposite spin you
could also be any roads you know any
angle within the plane it's always like
so it didn't really matter you were
opposing
the main message and the main message
was bad
yeah so you were you know the you were
allied by that we see it with the the
far right the hate the online hate as
well
they often disagree some of them will
these far-right groups one of them will
want to united europe the other wants to
break it up and live in tribes in the
caves
um and yet that never gets played out
because they're both opposing the things
that they
um they rail against i have to ask
certainly the
the way that you suggest thinking about
um the spread of the
misinformation is remarkably analogous
to the spread of the actual physical
virus
that gets from person to person you know
is that right how good is that analogy
is it more or less the same kind of
thing or are there like secret
differences that
make all the difference there's a fan
that is a fantastic question i just came
off last week of the back of the world
health organization's first
conference i was doing this leading the
one of the science
teams at the first conference on
infodemiology
i've never heard of that word and they
told me well you've never heard of it
because it didn't exist
um they put together their earlier claim
that the online
misinformation was like an infodemic
which we you know which
after that that was a few months ago
with the idea of
hey maybe we should be there for
thinking of an infoedemyology
to think about the online world but
there are a few
important differences number one is that
i can
sneeze on one place and
um somebody catches the cold or whatever
um
on the other side of the on the other
side of
the planet instantly because it's online
so the the notion of distance what does
it mean to social distance online that's
world certainly not a strategy
yeah yes so um certainly that's not a
strategy but there
are strategies that one thing we've
we've just finished a piece of work
we've tried
we tried to calculate the the
a lot of governments managed to
seemingly manage to
handle the situation talking about the r
number
which is basically the number of people
if you're if you're infected how many
people are you going to infect before
you recover
because if you infect another one and
then you recover well you just
you're just propagating the same
situation if you infect more than one
you're you're the things expanding
if you in fact less than one which you
know probabilistically you could
um then it's going to die out in time so
this r number whether it's bigger than
one or less than one is an important
number
but interestingly it is
it's calculated for um
in in a very in many ways a kind of ad
hoc way
in the epidemiology literature so the
idea is wait
because one of the reasons is that they
just don't know the network
that people are in and you know people
are in networks all the time and they
may be in a social network and yet never
meet the person they're
you know not meet them for five days or
something so
in a way they're forced to think about
epidemiology is forced to think about
disease propagation again like a test
tube a stick in a test tube
susceptible people and
a couple of infecteds they gradually all
become infect
infected and then they recover and so
i've got that reaction
problem and so that's how you tend to
define the r number
mathematically in all these the model
and the science that we always hear
about
on in in government um
updates but what does that become in the
online world because in the online world
we have
although you can instantly infect
someone on the other side of the planet
there are different universes in the
sense of
facebook is its own universe but it has
no interaction commercially with
something like uh gab
which is another social media platform
or with
4chan which is quite a um it's quite an
infamous um
you know it's a very very relatively
free and on
unregulated platform they're separate
universes and yet
people tunnel between them so if i mean
i literally think of this as universes
with some kind of wormhole between them
that people can go
through across space and unfortunately
because they're recording you know
because a lot of the postings
you can pull them up from um so-called
time machine
um you know yeah casual pages it's
almost like across
time as well so so postings come across
time
and space so it's almost like a wormhole
but you have to excuse me on this one
but it's
it is like a wormhole and that and that
these universes therefore are connected
in some
some it's almost like some kind of
multiverse so
in a way it's again of course i'm biased
but it's a perfect place
for physicists to jump in and think well
i
i like to think about multiverses i like
to think about universes i like to think
about
couplings and these wormholes can come
and go um
because they get shut down and sometimes
they get opened up again
um but they're very real things and so
you've got a spreading
phenomenon in that multiply connected
space
which is interesting very interesting
yeah
um is it is it
so but i i don't know physicists would
be good at this because i mean we we gab
about wormholes but usually we like
talking about smooth spacetimes i think
that's uh
that's that's our comfort zone we should
be better at talking about these these
sort of
fractally connected places yes you're
absolutely right so
it does become a uh kind of spreading in
a some kind of
fractally connected space exactly as you
said
and what is being spread isn't as clean
as
just a virus and no virus it's mutating
it's there are multiple versions of it
um and so i think it's an abs
it's a fascinating challenge this
infodemiology and it's going to become
huge because as we get more
uh you know some of these vaccines come
on i mean already
the rumors around some of these vaccines
are just
remarkable and there are many of them
and who knows it's impossible that they
all go well
some of them will go very well and
that's just science that's the way it
goes
um but the the the the the
opportunity for miss and disinformation
is
absolutely huge so i i think there's a i
mean just
putting on that the science hat for a
moment that's a fascinating problem
[Laughter]
right so the science head as opposed to
like the moral or
you know policy hat which is which is it
can be frustrating
absolutely freaking out yeah well okay
so
for one last little freak out um just to
close things i'll get to one of my
favorite issues here which is
how what are the implications of these
kinds of ideas for the very functioning
of democracy itself
right there is this idea that we need an
informed
populous but the very notion of what it
meant to be informed was different 200
years ago than it is now i mean are we
going to have to rethink
what it means to be a citizen of a
democratic
uh society or is it even a challenge to
the idea
if people can sort of fall into these
local minima
of crazy misinformation and that's
that's never going to go away
yeah that's a fan that's absolutely
important and fantastic question i do
see this um this issue i i don't think
science has ever had
a situation whereby it's being done in
real time
and the whole world is on top of
every preprint and every kind of
mr and discussing well i mean imagine
any of our own
any of us in doing our own bit of
science if suddenly every pre-print you
wrote
was hauled over the you know and then
you know discussed in facebook
kind of online communities and the
limitations section was just expanded
into some kind of list of of of uh
of problems with science to be fair it
is better than being ignored right
well there well that's an interesting
that's an interesting uh
question to to answer i i wonder
sometimes
but the idea that um that the trust in
science and the science science
if if we all know this if any science if
there is no if there if there were no
one if there were no unknowns in science
we wouldn't have a job
so um science is full of unknowns but
that but
how to stop that being perceived as
uncertainty in science
is i think a huge challenge and so
i actually think that that i'm biased
again but i actually think
that is the core of what's going to go
ahead in
i think democracy i'm not a
political expert in any way but i do
think that science is a key driver
and um i think
trust in science is something that is
absolutely central to this going forward
and people need to somehow the public we
could win a pub when a pub
when when are we all we're we're members
of the public when are we all going to
trust politicians well maybe never
you know maybe some of them one day some
of them but science
science is sort of like yeah the breadth
of
okay we understand that they're trying
to get the answers we understand that
they may not always have the answers we
have
that kind of level of trust i think is
absolutely
key going forward and i think it
underlies all these other
issues because as soon as you start
losing trust in science
you start just who can you trust who can
you then trust i mean
you know we all love members of our
family i have members of my family
who've given me
advice on covid that i would i'd
probably be six feet under if i took it
um i love them however they
i don't trust them on the science well
it's a need to trust
you know i think this is a genuinely
subtle
sticky difficult problem because i mean
obviously
yes i would love people to trust science
more than they do
on the other hand there's two other
hands one is that science
is the paradigmatic bottom-up thing
right where there's no pope of science
who tells us what the truth is there's
people
who disagree with each other and fight
and you know they battle and try to
agree
so when you say trust science it's not
clear
who you're trusting and the other is
that even you know
scientists are biased and wrong
sometimes too so the trust can't be even
absolute so i i'm
i'm torn about this i i want more trust
but not absolute trust
yeah no you're abs you're absolutely
right and and you know and i know that
you know if we took members of you know
people people saw what goes on in
conferences
with the arguing in the in the corridors
and the
you know the backstabbing in terms of
you know your theory my theory
and such but that so when i mean trusted
science i do not mean
trust in one particular result in
science right
exactly i mean trust in the process
yeah and so that and so just as
democracy is a process and we don't have
to necessarily trust one thing or
another i think
trust and trust in science you know it's
not
the result of any particular paper
it's the actual process and so this idea
that you could go to a conference and
there'd be people
we've seen it we've all seen it shouting
in the halls at each other
and you know kind of like uh almost like
separate
groups in particle theory you know that
won't even talk to each other
but we know this we know these stories
in the same department
in the same department but that but
they've been in but that that's
probably necessary that's how humans do
it you know it's the crowd and the
anti-crowd
together they make the the system that's
right
the thing we should have trust in is
that emergent process that uh
yes in the long term anyway we're
allowed to critique it in the middle
term but uh in the long term
we think that we're we're aiming in a
good direction scientifically speaking
correct
correct well that gives us some hope i
always like to i always tell my guests i
like to end on an optimistic
note and that sounds like an optimistic
note to me after you've given us some
some more sobering things to think about
so neil johnson thanks so much for being
on the minds game thank you so much
this is great thank you so much thank
you it's been a pleasure thank you
[Music]
you